what did you learn about machine
learning about engineering about life
about yourself as one human being from
working with Elon Musk
I think the most I've learned is about
how to sort of run organizations
efficiently and how to
create efficient organizations and how
to fight entropy in an organization so
human Engineering in the fight against
entropy yeah there's a there's a I think
Elon is a very efficient Warrior uh in
the fight against entropy in
organizations what is the entropy in an
organization look like exactly it's it's
process it's it's process and
inefficiencies and that kind of stuff
yeah meetings he hates meetings he keeps
telling people to skip meetings if
they're not useful he basically runs the
world's biggest uh startups I would say
uh Tesla SpaceX are the world's biggest
startups Tesla actually is multiple
startups I think it's better to look at
it that way and so I think he's he's
extremely good at uh at that and uh yeah
he's a very good intuition for
streamline processes making everything
efficient uh best part is no part uh
simplifying focusing
um and just kind of removing barriers
moving very quickly making big moves all
this is a very startupy sort of seeming
things but at scale it's a strong drive
to simplify from you from your
perspective I mean that
um that also probably applies to just
designing systems and machine learning
and otherwise like simplify simplify yes
what do you think is the secret to
maintaining the startup culture in a
company that grows is there
can you introspect that
I do think you need someone in a
powerful position with a big hammer like
Elon who's like the cheerleader for that
idea and ruthless ruthlessly pursues it
if no one has a big enough Hammer
everything turns into committees
democracy within the company uh process
talking to stakeholders decision making
just everything just crumbles yeah if
you have a big person who's also really
smart and has a big hammer things move
quickly